大家好,我是一池,今天我们来讲一个机构和庄家偏爱的指标,它就是不会骗人的OBV能量潮指标,它能让你少走十年弯路
OBV通常是一个领先于价格的指标,所以说我们通常说价格未动能量先行
学会了OBV这个指标了,它能让你提前发现机构和庄家的意图以及对于判断趋势都是非常有帮助的
律师Trader的油管频道
专注于加密货币交易和投资
欢迎点赞订阅
开启小铃铛就能第一时间
收到新视频的通知了
视频内容呢
主要包括能量潮指标OBV的简介
它的特点
它的交易法则
以及最重要的是OBV在实战中的应用
好我们首先来看能量潮指标OBV的简介
能量潮指标OBV呢
它的英文名称叫Unbalanced Volume
它是葛兰伟呢
于1960年代提出来的
并被广泛的使用
我们知道技术分析的四大要素是啥
是价量时空是吗
那么OBV指标呢
就是从成交量
从量这个要素呢
作为突破口
分析股价运动趋势的一种技术指标
OBV指标呢
将市场的人际
也就是成交量和价格的关系呢
数字化直观化
以市场的成交量变化
来衡量市场的推动力
从而研判价格的一种走势
那么OBV的计算量是非常简单的
OBV指标的OBV值呢
主要是计算的什么
累积成交量
那么当日的OBV值呢
就等于本日的一个值
加上前一日的OBV值
那么本日值怎么计算呢
那么如果K线收阳线的话
那本日值啊
就是成交量
就是为正值
那么如果说
当天的K线收阴线呢
本日值呢
就是成交量
那么它是负值
那么因此说
通过这个计算
我们很容易就得到OBV了
就等于你选定周期的
所有阳线的成交量之和
减去所有阴线的成交量之和
那这就是一个累积的成交量
能量潮指标OBV的特点
从OBV的计算过程我们知道
OBV是一个成交量的连续的累积值
它每天都会根据收盘价的变化
来相应的变化
当K线收阳线时
表明多头赢得了当日的战斗
那么当天的成交量
就加到了这个累积的OBV值上面去
如果说当K线收阴线的时候
表明当天的空头获胜了
那么当天的成交量
就要从OBV的累积的值里面
干啥
减去
如果是收盘价没有变化
则OBV值也保持不变
从这个计算过程
我们知道
OBV的涨跌了
往往是提前与价格涨跌的
是一种先行的指标
因此我们经常说啥
先见量
后见价
或者说价格未动
能量先行
我们来看能量潮指标
OBV的交易法则
总结下来主要有下面四点第一点OBV确认趋势沿着OBV指标确认的趋势方向操作更加安全当OBV与价格同涨同跌时
那么趋势就得到了确认
如果价格创新高
且OBV值也创出新高
则上升趋势有望延续
如果价格创新低
且OBV值也创出新低
则下跌趋势有望延续
第二点
当OBV创出新高时
它确认了多方的势力
表明了价格可能会继续走高
发出了买入信号
当OBV创出新低的时候
他确认了空方的市民
表明了价格可能会继续走低
发出卖出信号
其实第二点
我觉得还是确认趋势的原则
第三点
当OBV与价格出现背离的时候
发出了强烈的买入信号和卖出信号
也就是背离是一个比较重要的信号
那么同时长周期的背离
是比短周期的背离更重要的
比如说周K线级别的背离
是比日线级别重要的
那么日线级别的背景
是比4小时级别重要的
第四点
当价格乘区间震荡
IOBV向上突破
创出新高时
发出了一个买入信号
当价格乘区间震荡
IOBV向下突破
创出新低时
发出一个卖出信号
那这第四点是非常重要的
这个就是价格未动
量能先行的一个非常重要的信号
它对我们判断趋势
提前发出了一个预警的信号
最重要的是我们要学会如何在实战中
来应用OBV这个能量槽指标来判断趋势
来预测趋势
首先我们在Tradivill中的K线上
我们要添加OBV这个指标
在这个指标策略这一块点击一下
然后搜索中输入OBV
这个指标其实是官方类质的一个指标
因此说你直接点击它就可以添加到图表上
那么添加到图表上
大家可以看到下面就有一条线
那么我们把OBV这个指标给它设置一下
点开齿龙
那么在输入这块呢
我们把这个长度
就是一条线
我们给它加一个均线
比如说加个20
如果你喜欢菲莫拉切数列呢
你可以设置成21
然后在样式这一块呢
把这个平滑线也给它画出来
然后这个线宽呢
颜色你可以自己去改一下
好我设置好之后呢
这个OBV就两条线呢
这个白色的细线呢
就是这个OBV值
这个黄线呢
就是它的一个20均线
那么在OBV的具体的实战中
其实它比较重要的就是
它会确认趋势
也就是沿着OBV确认趋势的方向操作了
是比较安全的
比如说那么我们就了
以眼前的这个过去两年的流市为例
我们来举这个例子
比如说那么在从1万涨到这个是
大概了就是4万的这一段趋势中
是不是它的价格在创新高
那么OBV值呢也在不断的创新高也就是它这个上升趋势呢在OBV的角度我们看它是安全的它是确认了这个上升趋势比如说从今年的4月份
到目前的这个比特币的下降趋势
我们可以看到
在价格不断创新低的过程中
它的OBV值
其实也在不断的创新低
那么这个就是确认了趋势的方向
也就是从这个角度
讲目前的下跌趋势
可能还会继续的可能是大的
那么从OBV确认趋势的角度讲
只要他的这个OBV呢
一直在创新高
那么这个价格呢
可能就会一直走高
只要他的OBV值呢
一直干啥创新低
他的价格可能会一直创新低
但是呢
行情不可能一直创新高
或者一直创新低
是吗
就上升趋势总会结束
那下降趋势呢
也总会反转
一旦说是发出了价格和OBV的
背离的信号呢
这是一个非常重要的信号
意外的趋势可能要
要反转
那么我们来举例看一下
比如说是在2021年的1月份的时候
那么这一段趋势
那这个价格是从41,000涨到多少
涨到55,000是吗
那么它同期的OBV呢
我们看到价格在创新高
OBV呢并没有创新高
那么这个呢
就是一个价格和OBV指标的背离
提示了这个上升趋势了
可能已经不安全了
很显然了
行情经过一段正常时间之后了
那么可以说这个阶段性的流失就结束了
这就是一个上升趋势的重要的背离信号
意外的趋势的反转
那么比如说是2021年10月份到11月份
那么比特币到达最高价69,000的时候
其实它的价格还在创新高
但是我们可以看一下它的OBV值
它的OBV值是再也没有到前高的阻力位
也就是出现了价格跟OBV指标的背离了
后面就迎来了整整的
今年10个月的这一龙大的巡视
那么价格和OBV底背离的例子呢
貌似是不太多的
那么我找到了一处21年的
六七月份的这个行情
比如说我们从日线级别收线的角度讲
那么这个收线呢是创了新低的
但是我们同时可以看到
它的OBV指标呢
在价格创新低的时候
它并没有跌破前低
也就是出现了价格和OBV指标的底背离
那底背离呢
意味着这段下跌的调整周期啊
可能会结束
那么果然呢
后面就迎来了
七月份的一种单边上涨趋势
那么综合来看呢
OBV和价格的这个关系呢
是OBV确认趋势
一旦是OBV不确认趋势了
那么就会发生背离
背离呢
是个非常重要的信号
当然了背离之后
价格不一马上就跌是吧
那么我们参考21年的这个
年初的这个行情
它在发生背离之后
其实它是还走了一个
中长期的顶部的派发结构
价格才跌下来
但是无论如何
这个OBV量能指标的背离呢绝对是给我们在这个顶部提供了一个预警的信号能量炒指标OBV的另一个非常重要的应用呢
就是价格未动量能先行
比如说我们来举个例子
比如说20年的7月份到10月份的这一段行情
其实呢我们现在看
它在日线级别走的基本上就是这么一个上升三角形
那么它对应的同期的OBV量能指标的形态是个什么样子呢
傍大图形看的话
其实呢
在比特币走日线级别的上升三角形震荡的时候
它的一个OBV的指标呢
也走了一个小的区间震荡
但是我们看到在这一天的时候
OBV指标呢
发出了向上突破创新高的举动
我们对上去
那么它的这个价格在啥地方呢
大概呢
就在这个位置
那这个位置突破这个三角形呢
还没有
那这个就是我们说的啥
价格未动量能先行
是不是
量能呢
是首先确认了
那么这是一个上升的趋势
并且它会创新高
同时我们看到后面有个价格
是之后与它的向上突破了这个形态
然后迎来了流市的爆发
也就是说价格在区间震荡的时候
如果说OBV向上了突破前高
创了新高
那这个就是一个买入信号
提前我们一定要做好趋势
很可能会向上爆发
比如说比特币在2021年的2月份到5月份的时候
其实它这个头部走了一个通道
或者我们说是一个上升楔形
那么它同期的OBV结构是什么样子的
我们可以看到基本上在这个头部
它的同期的OBV的形态
基本上是一个三角形
那么在这一天的时候
可以看到OBV跌破三角形
创了价新低了什么
那么其实它的价格还在区间中正当
当它跌破这个形态的时候
就对我们发出了非常提前的
非常重要的一个预警信号
那么趋势了可能的方向就是向下
果然了后面在走了还比较长之后
那么这个价格就跌破了这个形态
比如说比特币在2021年的年底的时候
那么这个K线走的这个是一个啥形态
这是一个上升楔形
我们看它的同期的OBV形态是什么样子的
我们可以看到它同期的是这么一个形态
不管怎么说它在第二跌破这条趋势线
也就是跌破这个形态的时候了
它的价格其实还在区间震荡之内
那么就对我们发出了提前预警的信号
那么趋势了可能会发生改变
而且我们可以看到在这个价格创新高的时候
它的OBV值是创了新低
那这个就是一个顶背离是吧
那么这双重的信号对后市确认可能趋势会发生改变
可能是向下的
好以上就是OBV指标最重要的应用
它的确认趋势
它的背离信号
它在正当行情中提前于价格选择方向
对我们指示趋势的信号
对我们判断趋势预测行情都是非常有帮助的
有任何其他问题呢
可以加视频下方的discord社群进群讨论
好欢迎点赞订阅开启小铃铛
我们下期视频再见